officials in North Carolina say it could
be days before power is restored after
two substations were shot up over the
weekend it's cold there too a tough time
for thousands to be in the dark and
officials are trying to find a motive
for what they call a deliberate attack
on local infrastructure Mark Strassman
is there in Carthage North Carolina for
us Mark good morning
Good morning Tony for thousands of
residents here this is the third
straight morning of waking up to a cold
house still no power still no suspects
in this targeted attack
traffic lights are out
generators are on and people in Moore
County North Carolina feel challenged by
crisis it's devastating authorities say
someone with a gun broke through a gate
and intentionally opened fire at two
power substations in Moore County what's
the temperature in the house right now
it's probably about 55. Steve and Meg
Wilkins are bracing for another
uncomfortable night take you off
absolutely
uh this is not what I wanted to be doing
today stringing power cords eating cold
ham you know and uh trying to live by
flashlights in the evening roughly 35
000 customers are without power and will
be for most of the week until Crews
repair and replace equipment protecting
critical infrastructure like our power
system
must be a top priority in January CBS
News obtained a bulletin from the
Department of Homeland Security warning
that domestic violent extremists
continue to plot credible specific plans
to attack electricity infrastructure
U.S has 55 000 substations earlier this
year 60 Minutes profiled how lightly
protected and vulnerable they often are
there's very few number of substations
you need to take out in the entire
United States to knock out the entire
grid turns out taking out fewer than 20
critical substations all at once could
block out the entire country the way
Moore County looks today this kind of
attack raises a new level of threat
we will be evaluating ways to make sure
that we Harden our infrastructure to
prevent future damage
the FBI has joined state and local
officials investigating who's behind all
this as for restoring power fingers
crossed could be Thursday
Nate
fingers crossed that's for sure mark
thank you